we are just a few months away from the
primary elections in both republican and
democrat parties really ramping up
efforts to get the community to register
to vote christian casada is joining in
now in studio with exactly who they are
targeting this time around kristin will
brian denise a key demographic this
election season latinos but for some
residents that i spoke to today they say
they might be holding out on the
elections
are you registered to vote the countdown
is on to get southern nevada residents
registered to vote for the upcoming
november midterm elections
pop-up sites like this one for the gop
on the corner of eastern and bonanza is
hoping to grow their latino base
but residents say this election will be
different because many are tired of
unfulfilled campaign promises
elia molina says she is voting for a
change and not for a specific candidate
what we continue to sell is the
republican
values and principles particularly for
hispanics they really identify
themselves with the party that
defends
freedom and opportunities democrats not
wasting any time and pushing their own
message natalie hernandez with make the
road action nevada has been an organizer
for 10 years she's been fighting for
immigration reform since her father was
deported in 2011. i used my story i used
other stories like mine to help keep
people motivated and let them know that
like this isn't a fight that we're gonna
win in one two three four years both
parties tell us residents can expect
more outreach as election day gets
closer and a great chance for latinos to
address concerns like immigration and
the economy the violence and
everywhere there's a lot of killing and
all over the city
well both parties tell us residents
can't be the change they want unless
they register to vote for the november
8th elections now we have a link on our
website to register or maybe just update
your information that's 8newsnow.com
christian costa is live local now